How you doing, man? Are you a Muslim?
Why?
>> Oh, sorry about that. I didn't know you
had me.
>> You're a Muslim?
>> Yep.
>> What message do you believe that Paul
corrupted?
>> All right. So, I don't directly believe
that Paul corrupted like a specific
message, but just like based off like
some readings that I see, it's more that
he like he deferred a little bit from
the teaching of Jesus. It just like
makes him less reliable, I feel.
>> Okay. Where where do we find the
teachings of Jesus specifically? like
through like the Bible. Is that what you
mean?
>> Okay. Okay. Nice. Yes. Okay. So, we get
the teachings of Jesus in the Bible and
you're saying that Paul deviated from
the teachings that we find of Jesus in
the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> And so if somebody deviates from what
Jesus taught in the Bible, then they are
untrustworthy. They're unreliable.
>> Yeah. like he just he just like not
necessarily he's unreliable but it's
just that like it makes the entire thing
unreliable if there's like and like
someone who's going against or not
against but like slightly deviating
away.
>> Yeah, I got you.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Deviating from the message of
Jesus in the Bible then the whole
message is is unreliable. Yeah.
>> No, that's I don't like it's it's more
that like it makes it less reliable. I
don't think you can cross out the whole
message just because of one thing.
>> All right. So, sorry. Let me let me just
be clear. Let me just ask you a very
clear question.
>> Y
>> if Paul deviates from the message of
Jesus, does that make Paul unreliable?
>> Yep.
>> All right. So, whoever deviates from the
message of Jesus, that person is
unreliable, right?
>> In like unreliable to be used as a
teacher in Christianity. Yeah. I I I I'm
confused here because now you're
>> qualif like like what I mean is that
like if Paul's deviating from the
message of Jesus then we shouldn't use
Paul as
>> I got you as anything. He's not he's a
false teacher. Right.
>> Sure.
>> So whoever
>> put exactly that way but
>> but whoever deviates from the message of
Jesus we shouldn't take their message.
They're a false teacher or they have a
false message. Right.
>> In Christianity. Yeah.
>> Why do you keep qualifying and saying in
Christianity? I think I think what
you're trying to to get to the point is
is that in Islam, Muhammad deviated away
or like how you're trying to say is that
he deviated is not the same message as
the one that you believe Jesus read.
>> But this is your standard. It's not
mine. So you can't you can't flip-flop
on your own standard.
>> No, what I what I mean is cuz I don't
believe I'm I'm sure you know this, but
I don't believe that the Bible is the
teaching of Jesus.
>> But that you did but earlier you said
you believe the Bible.
>> But that's what you believe in. Like if
you want to ask what I then do.
>> No, my brother. So, we'll we'll do this
again. I asked you I could replay it,
but I'll just run us through it.
>> I I'm No, I I agree that I said that,
but what I what I meant was Yeah. I I
mean, I don't mean that you were wrong.
I'm saying that like it's like I don't
believe that. But
>> then why did you say it if you don't
believe it? Cuz I asked you. I didn't
ask you what I believe. I asked you
where do you find the teachings of
Jesus? You said the Bible.
>> That's not what I believe. I'm just I
just said that because that's
>> So, you lied to me.
>> Sure. I I said it. I said a lie.
>> So, can we promise not to lie to each
other from here on out?
>> Yeah. Yeah. My bad, man. I just I didn't
mean it like in a bad way, you know? I
was just like,
>> it's okay. Let's Let's uh let's start
over.
>> Yeah.
>> What message do you believe that Paul
corrupted?
>> Okay. So, I believe that in the Bible
specifically, not what I believe, but in
the Bible specifically, Paul says
certain things that deviate away from
what the Bible says Jesus taught.
>> What does that matter? Because that's
not what Jesus taught anyway. Right.
>> Yeah. That's what you Okay. So, we're
arguing cuz the thing is, right?
>> We're not arguing what I believe or what
you believe. We're arguing objectivity.
>> Exactly.
>> So, what message do you believe Paul
corrupted?
>> Okay. For example, um in Matthew 5 verse
17 to 18,
>> don't do that again. Don't stop. Is
Matthew 5 the teaching of Jesus?
>> I don't believe it is.
>> So, what message do you believe Paul
corrupted? Do you let me let me just ask
you this straight up. Do you believe
that Paul corrupted the message of
Jesus?
>> It's it's a like I can't say directly
yes or no because it's like I don't
believe like I don't believe that the
Bible is his teachings.
>> So
Bible's out then. Do you believe that
contradict a question?
>> Can I ask?
>> No, you got No, you have to answer this
one first. My brother,
>> what's the question? What's the
question?
>> You don't know the question.
>> I So I didn't hear you properly. Like I
I said you answered the first question,
but you asked me a follow-up question. I
didn't hear it.
>> Are you focused?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You're not playing any video games over
there or nothing?
>> No, right now. I was before this.
>> Okay. So, you put it down and you're
you're talking straight to me.
>> All right. Do you believe Yes or no? Do
you believe that Paul corrupted the
message of Jesus?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> Somewhat.
>> All right. Cool. Yes, somewhat. All
right. Step two. Where do we find the
message of Jesus? I don't think you can
anymore.
>> Got it. So, back to step here's step
three. Then, how do you know that Paul
corrupted the message of Jesus if we do
not have the message of Jesus to check?
>> See, this this is this is what this is
what I was going to ask you. You believe
in the Bible, correct?
>> It's not what I It's not about what I
believe. It's about what we are
objectively saying. And it's about what
your position is. And so, showing how
your position is untenable, it makes
it's it's it's so baseless. You're
saying, "Yeah, Paul corrupted the
teachings of Jesus." At the same time,
we don't have the teachings of Jesus. So
then, which begs the question, then how
the heck do you know? How do you know
that Paul corrupted the message of Jesus
if you don't have it? If we don't have
it,
>> this is this is why this is why it's not
about what you believe or what I
believe, but I don't I don't think that
we have the teaching of Jesus, but you
do. So,
>> it's not about what I think. Again, you
you just said that. you just said
instead about what I believe you
believe. You just repeated it. So why do
you keep doing what? Don't appeal to me.
>> I can't help you. This is your position.
>> We don't have it. It doesn't matter what
I think.
>> We don't have it according to you.
>> Yeah.
>> So according to your position, I need
you to make it tenable. Get build like
some concrete. So give yourself to stand
on because you're falling. You're you're
standing on air. How do you know? How do
you know that Paul corrupted the
teachings of Jesus if we don't have it
anymore?
>> I guess that I don't.
>> Very good. So, you don't know if Paul
corrupted the teachings of Jesus or not?
What when we read Paul's letters, he
very well could be uh right in line with
what Jesus taught, right? As far as we
know. Huh.
>> Theoretically, yeah, I guess
>> theoretically. So,
so to say that Paul corrupted the
teachings of Jesus for the position that
you hold, you cannot say that, right?
>> That's why that's why I said like
somewhat because as I said in the
beginning, I don't fully believe that he
did. I said he just deviated from what
the Bible's message is.
>> But notice how do you notice how
irrelevant that is? Bringing up the
Bible if it's not the teachings of Jesus
is irrelevant to our topic, our
conversation. the Bible is irrelevant.
That's like you asking me uh um do you
believe that um man was in line with the
Quran or with the message of Muhammad? I
say h well you know there there's a
little bit of what Uman says that aligns
with Harry Potter a little bit of that
you know um I don't believe that Harry
Potter was real necessarily. I do
believe that there are some kind of real
aspects to it. You see how like what why
why am I talking about Harry Potter when
you're asking about the message of
Muhammad, you know? So I'm asking about
the message of Jesus if the Bible
impossible for me to base and argue off
anything if I don't believe it existed.
>> Very good. So it's impossible for you to
Good. So it's impossible for you to hold
a position that Paul corrupted the
teaching of Jesus. Right.
>> Yeah. Once again, that's why I didn't
say like definitively. Yes, he did.
>> You can't say definitively nothing. You
can't say somewhat. You can't say a
little bit. You can't say, "Oh, maybe."
You can't say nothing. You can't say
that.
>> Yeah, I guess I can though.
>> Okay. So, let me show you the issue with
this. Because with this conversation,
you kept trying to appeal to my Bible
because that's all you got. The Bible is
all you got to give you some inclination
of what Jesus was saying and doing, but
you reject that. So with that being
said, if I were to ask you for example,
why why do you reject the gospel that I
have as the in jail?
>> Okay. So first of all, there is verses
in the Quran that say that talk about it
and as well I struggle to believe that
so the the Bible Matthew like the New
Testament was written after Jesus.
Correct.
>> Yep.
>> So how did he preach it before it was
written? What?
>> How did he preach the gospel if it was
written after him?
>> He cuz he preached the gospel orally and
then his disciples and folks wrote it
down after he left.
>> But like a lot of the things that are
are in like the the gospel say like they
talk specifically from like the
perspectives of like there's some verses
talk from the perspectives of
>> Yeah, exactly. They like So how did was
he like
>> does the Bible also like compile other
things? Like I just like I
>> we're just talking about the gospel
specifically. The gospel that I have
records what Jesus said and did.
>> But then why does it have like Yeah. But
like I just understand why it also has
extra things
>> like what
>> like why does it have stories from the
perspectives of Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John and Paul? And
>> it's all of them is geared towards what
Jesus did. The gospel has nothing to do
with Paul. This is before Paul. So do
you have a problem with the gospel ride
authors writing after Jesus left?
>> No. But it's just that like doesn't does
does m does um Mark I'm pretty sure does
he not say that this is the gospel of of
>> that of the this is the gospel of Jesus
the talk of the kingdom or something. So
like so do they it's like a compilation
of what he did after but it's not like
directly
>> it has nothing to do with what he did
after. They're recording what he did
what he said and what he did.
>> So it's like a historical like
perspective. Well, it is a it's it's a
historical perspective on the gospel.
That's what the gospel is. It's what
Jesus did and said.
>> Uh-huh. Okay. And then another issue I
have is that there's some verses that I
find are kind of
>> Wait, wait. Why is that an issue? You
said another issue you have. Why? Why is
this an issue?
>> Cuz I I misunderstood it. My
understanding was incorrect.
>> Oh, okay. So, this is not is no longer
an issue.
>> It's not an issue. No, no, no. That's
all.
>> So, then why so why do you reject the
gospel that I have as the gospel?
>> I'm I'm giving you other things as well
right now. Okay. So, some verses in the
I believe it's in the Old Testament,
they talk about certain laws that I
don't agree with at all. For example, I
don't know. I don't I forgot the exact
verse, but
>> wait, what is the Old That's What is the
The Old Testament has What does that
have to do with the gospel? Why you
reject the gospel that I have? Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John being the angel?
>> Because Because you cut out what you say
at the very very end. You said I Why do
I reject as the jail? Why do you why do
you reject Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
as being the angel?
>> I don't separate them. I take Old
Testament, New Testament together.
That's the Bible. I reject the Bible.
No.
>> Yeah. But I'm talking about the angel
specifically, brother. The Bible is the
collection of all of these scriptures.
So the Bible contains the Torah. It
contains the Zub, the Psalms. It
contains uh the writings of other
prophets. It contains the other letters
of the apostles. And it contains the
gospel. So specifically separate like
>> so are the rest of the things not also
teachings of Jesus? Not everything is
directly teachings of Jesus, you know,
like
>> not directly but like related to his
message
>> like related. Sure. But it's not not
everything not everything is the gospel.
Like you go to the Old Testament.
>> Hold on. You're not you got to listen,
bro. You go to the Old Testament like
you go to the book of Judges has is
nothing to do with the gospel.
>> Okay. But does he not agree with like
his teachings are correlated with
everything? Even if it's not his
teachings, but he agrees. No, nothing
contradicts. Nothing contradicts. My
question is specifically on the gospel.
Why do you say that the gospel that I
have is not the angel?
>> Okay. Can I pull up some contradictions
real quick? Let me just check my verses.
I think it's like Kings 2. One sec.
>> Do you do you hear what I'm saying?
>> Yeah, I do.
>> So, why are you trying to go to a
contradiction in Kings that has nothing
to do with the gospel?
>> It's Kings in the Old Testament.
>> Yes.
>> That's my bad then. Give me one second.
So, do you do you have a reason why you
reject what I have as the is the NGO the
gospel specifically?
>> I'm not fully versed in it. No, not
really. Like,
>> so so man, you're a Muslim, right?
>> Yep.
>> How long have you been a Muslim?
>> 3 months.
>> You've been a Muslim for 3 months?
>> Yep.
>> What were you before?
>> Agnostic.
>> You're agnostic. Okay. So, you never
read the Bible before?
>> I've read some of it. I've been to
perform at some churches and I while I'm
sitting in the stands, I'd like to read
the Bible. So, so have you ever read the
Gospel?
>> I haven't read the Old Testament. I've
read some of the I think I read Mark,
but I haven't read Matthew, Luke, and
John yet.
>> Okay. So, the reason why this is
important, bro, is because to to deny
what something what something is, like
you have to have information about, you
have to know about it. You know what I'm
saying?
>> Yeah. So when the Quran appeals to the
gospel and says that the Jew that uh the
Christians have it with them in their
possession in the 7th century in
Muhammad's time and says that it's
Allah's word and this is historically
what we know the gospel to be. Muslims
have no ground to say that what we have
is not what the go the gospel that the
Quran's talking about. It's literally
all they had. You get what I'm saying?
You there?
>> Hello.
>> There you go.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, I can hear you now.
>> Okay. I cut off after you said that we
you said like we relate to the the
gospel.
>> Yeah. I was saying the Quran points to
the gospel. It says the gospel is the
word of Allah. It says that the people
of the gospel are supposed to judge by
it. Are you familiar with these verses?
>> Yeah.
>> So this means that the gospel that I
have is authoritative and it's the word
of God from the Quran's perspective. So
the Muslims have no ground.
>> But that's assuming that we're still
talking about the same thing. That's
that's where it differs. It's like
>> why why do you have what reason do you
have to believe that it's anything else?
>> Okay. Can I give a verse example from
the Bible or will you say that's also
baseless?
>> From the gospel.
>> Yeah. From the gospel. New Testament.
>> Yeah. So you're about to show me that
you're about to read me something in the
New Testament and you're about to say
this is not the gospel. How so? How do
you know?
>> Cuz it's a contradiction in it.
>> How do you know that the gospel didn't
have contradictions in it?
>> I don't believe something from the word
of God can have contradictions. You not
believe you believe in that is just
begging the question. Have you seen the
gospel yourself?
>> Like you mean like that what I believe
is that? No, but if it's from God, it
can't have any.
>> So how do you know that? How do you know
that the gospel didn't have
contradictions in it?
>> How can it have contradictions? If God
is perfect, he can't.
>> You're saying that you're saying that
the gospel that I have has
contradictions in it
>> and therefore it's not what the Quran's
talking about. How do you know that the
gospel the Quran's talking about is not
what I have that has a supposed
contradiction in it?
>> Okay. Cuz I believe that the Quran is
the word of No. No. Cuz I'm going like
it's a false it's I'm explaining. I'm
answering right. So the reason I don't
believe it's the same thing the Quran is
talking about is because I believe that
it's the word of God. And I'm assuming
and it says that it's the word of God.
>> And if it is the word of God, if it is
the word of God, if it is the word of
God, then how why is it going to have
>> I don't care. I don't care what we
believe. I don't I don't care. I don't
care what you personally believe or what
your personal conviction is. I only care
about what you know and what you can
prove or what you can give evidence for.
What is your evidence? Say that again.
>> I mean, how am I going to explain a
religion without having belief? Like,
>> well, uh, if your belief isn't founded
in anything, that's a that's a belief I
don't care about. If your belief has a
foundation and is based on evidence,
that's a belief I can consider. You get
you get the difference?
>> Yeah. I'm going to pro. So how I'm going
to do that is by giving a contradiction
in the Bible which means that if there's
a contradiction from it cannot be
perfect if there's a contradiction and
we agree on that
>> that would just mean that the Quran is
appealing to a book that has
contradictions in it.
>> Once again you're assuming that it's the
same thing.
>> You're and and here it is. You have to
give me something that demonstrates it's
not. Giving me a contradiction in it
doesn't tell me that it's not the same
book the Quran's talking about. That
would just mean the Quran is appealing
to a book with contradictions.
>> Okay. So, you want me to give you
something that's shows that it's not
appealing to the the gospel that we have
right now?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. One second. All right. So, if I
were to give you a verse that says that
the Quran has supreme authority over the
Bible and the Gospel and the Torah,
would you agree that that means it
doesn't rely on them?
>> Yeah, I would. Yep.
>> All right. So, in Surah 58,
>> Yep. verse 48.
>> It says, "We have revealed to you, O
prophet, this book with the truth as the
confirmation of previous scriptures and
the supreme authority on them." You want
me to keep reading? Yeah.
>> All right. So, judge between them by
what Allah has revealed and do not
follow their desires over the truth that
has come to you. To each of you, we have
ordained a code of law and a way of
life. If Allah has will, he would have
made you one community. But his will is
to test you by what he has given each of
you. So compete with one another in
doing good. To Allah, you will all
return. Then he will inform you of the
truth regarding your differences.
>> All right. So you see where that phrase
where it says supreme authority.
>> Yep. You said you you've only been a
Muslim for three months, so I don't
expect you to know this, but sometimes
in these translations, my brother, they
will really distort the Arabic.
>> I speak Arabic.
>> Oh, you speak Arabic.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, awesome. So, according to the
Arabic, what does the word Mahiman mean?
>> Let me read it.
>> You said you speak Arabic. You don't
know what?
>> Yeah, I do.
Uh, like a guardian kind of.
>> Yes, exactly. a guardian which is
exactly what it says. It is a guardian
wahiman and a guardian
>> of the previous scriptures not a supreme
authority. So this translation that you
read this English translation that says
supreme authority got that wrong. That's
actually reading into the Quran their
own interpretation. The Quran doesn't
say that. It says it's a guardian of the
previous scriptures not an authority
over them.
>> But how we understand the Quran as well
is based on the hadith. So I'm not sure
like this is me making an assumption but
maybe they translated it this way
because in a hadith
>> there's nowhere in the Quran that says
this either that says that the Quran is
an authority over the previous
scriptures. In fact I can show you that
it's the previous scriptures that's an
authority over the Quran. You want to
see that?
>> Sure.
>> All right. If we go to chapter 10 verse
>> let me pull it up.
>> All right. Verse 94.
>> Verse 94.
>> Yep. Yeah. I'm on it. Awesome. It says,
"And if you are in doubt concerning that
which we have revealed to you," talking
about the Quran, talking to Muhammad
about the Quran.
>> Yeah.
>> "Then go and ask those who read the
scripture before you, verily, the truth
has come to you from your Lord. So be
not of those who doubt." Right? So if
Muhammad is doubting what the Quran
says, what does Allah tell him to do?
>> Read the scriptures of before you.
Right. The Torah and the Gospel, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's the Torah and the Gospel that
can verify for Muhammad if what he's
getting from the Quran is true or not.
Right.
>> See, the only thing I'm going to say is
that like he didn't receive the Quran as
a book. He received it as a audibly. So,
>> yeah. No worries. So, what he's
receiving from the Quran, right? what
Gabriel is telling him of the Quran, the
way that he can check that this what
he's receiving is true in the Quran is
if he goes checks the previous
scriptures, right?
>> It says it says those who read the
scripture before you. So he doesn't
refer to the scripture. He should refer
to those who read it.
>> And those who read it will be getting
their information from where?
>> The old scriptures.
>> Exactly. So it's the scriptures that's
verifying if the Quran is true or not.
Right.
>> If he has any doubts. Yeah. Exactly. So
according to the verse, it's pointing to
the previous scriptures as being the
authority, not the Quran. So if the
Quran is not in line with the previous
scriptures, then Muhammad would have
good reason to doubt it and he'll know
that it's false. If it is in line, then
he'll have no reason to doubt the Quran
and he'll know that the Quran is true.
>> Yeah.
>> So according to the Quran, the previous
scriptures, the Torah, the Gospel, the
Psalms, that's the authority, not the
Quran.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Mhm.
>> This is this is why I as a Christian
judge the Quran to be false obviously
because the Quran contradicts the Bible.
It contradicts the Torah and the Gospel
and the Psalms at every turn.
>> Okay. I I have a question that's not
really related to the thing. I just have
a question for you. You were talking
about the gospel, but do you believe in
the Old Testament as like we were
talking about the gospel?
>> Do you know why we got here?
>> Yeah, I I do. That's why I just That's
why I said it's like unrelated. I have a
question.
>> Yeah. I'm only I'm I'm brother. I have a
I have a condition that I I cannot ever
get off topic and be comfortable with
myself. If I get off topic, I start to
itch, you know.
>> I don't want I don't want you to itch.
Let's
>> Yeah. I don't want you to itch.
>> Appreciate that, man. I appreciate the
love, bro. See, I knew you cared about
me. So, all of this all of this Let's
remind ourselves of the main point. Why
do you say that the gospel that I have
is not the gospel that the Quran is
referring to?
>> 100% honest.
>> It's what I heard Islamic scholars say.
>> I appreciate that, man.
>> Yep. Blind faith is what you heard them
say. They say the gospel's corrupted.
You know that we believe in the original
gospel. The original. You're m
>> as well. I think they're talking about
the Old Testament including the New. I
don't think they mean they say the
Bible. I never heard anyone say like the
go they always say the Bible.
>> Yeah. But that's what they're talking
about when they say the Bible. They're
talking about the Torah and Gospel cuz
that's what the Bible is. It's a
collection of both. It's a collection of
all those books. So
>> So I think they also include the Old
Testament cuz like in the Old Testament
there's certain things that are
>> that's fine and all but still notice all
this would prove is that you're just
disagreeing with Allah's books. Allah
says the Torah is good. Allah says the
gospel is good. So if you are saying
that there's laws in the Torah that are
heinous that you disagree with then
you're disagreeing with Allah. If you're
saying that the gospel is full of
contradictions, then you're disagreeing
with Allah and saying that he has a book
that's full of contradictions. That's
all you're doing. It's a lose-lose.
Look, if if the Torah and Gospel are
full of contradictions and immorality,
then the Quran is false for saying that
these books are true.
>> So if they're all false, then so what do
you believe it? that well the this shows
that the Quran is false not my books.
>> I if I think it's heinous then I then
that like you're I'm you're saying I
disagree with that. So I also disagree
with the other books cuz I think it's
heinous.
>> Well can All right. So let can we agree
then at least with this standpoint and
where we're at right now the Quran is
false for affirming books that have
contradictions and heinous laws.
>> Yeah.
>> And you just left Islam.
>> Sure.
>> You just left Islam, bro. You got to
stay out of there, man. And don't go
back. Don't go back. Is it true or not?
>> Still doesn't mean that I will go
Christianity, but like
>> that's true. All All I've done for you
so far is shown you why Islam is false.
I haven't proven to you that
Christianity is true yet. I just showed
you that without a shadow of a doubt,
logically, Islam is false because of
this internal contradiction that it has.
It confirms books that are so so-called
have contradictions and falsehood.
Therefore, the Quran is false for saying
false books are true. Now, if these
books are are true, let's say they're
not heinous or false. Let's say there's
no contradictions. They don't have vain
laws, they're good to go. Let's say
these books are good. If these books are
true, then the Quran is still false for
contradicting these true books. So,
either way,
>> false that that's it's kind of like a
it's kind of like a stale rate. Ex.
>> It's a double-edged sword. If the if the
Bible's good, the Quran is false for
going against the Bible. If the Bible's
bad, then the Quran is still false for
confirming the Bible.
>> But if it but
>> there's no way around it. No matter
what, the Quran is false. Can't it's
it's just nothing, you know, cuz the
internal content of the Quran. Um that's
how you know it's false.
>> So, so far the Quran is false logically
and objectively. I haven't proven the
Bible yet.
>> Yeah, you just disproved what?
>> I just disproved the Quran.
>> Step one.
>> All right. So, that's step one. So that
wall's broken down. You still a Muslim?
>> Nope. I guess not.
>> Praise God, man. Praise God. Now, let's
deal with your objections on the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> Why do Why is it that you're
disbelieving in the Bible?
>> The whole Bible.
>> Yeah. Anything. Yeah.
>> You You disbelieve the whole Bible.
>> Like Like what I mean is I ask you, you
don't mean the gospel. You mean the
whole thing. Like
>> I mean the gospel
>> New Testament. Do you mean like
>> why why specifically why do you
disbelieve in Jesus? Why do you not
believe his message? Why do you reject
his message?
>> I don't think it's fair to say that
someone had to die for the sins of
others.
>> Fair.
>> So like he I don't I I find it hard to
believe that God would have to let
someone die and especially himself. Like
how would he let himself die to get rid
of the sins of humanity?
>> Okay, good question. So why would God
have to die in order to get rid of the
sins of humanity? And is that
necessarily fair? I think that there's a
difference between what is fair and then
what is just. Okay? Because um I think
if we're looking at the justice of God,
I think that's a different conversation
because in God's justice, his law is
like for example, his law when it comes
to sin is shedding of blood. It's death.
The wage of sin, the price of sin is
death. That's what the price is. That's
what we all owe God without Jesus. We
owe him death and eternal death and
separation from him.
>> Why? If he's if he's all powerful, why
does he need us to die for that?
>> No, it's not that he needs us to it's
the consequence of sin. That's that's
what it is. The consequence of sin is
death. That's the consequence.
>> Okay. So, how he forgives us is by the
blood of Jesus. How he forgives us by
coming and giving his life appealing
appealing his law for us so that we
don't have to die.
>> So, so what I'm saying is why does he
need that death?
>> No, we need it.
>> Why can't he just forgive us? Yeah. No,
like why do we need the death of
somebody? Why can't he forgive us
without the death?
>> Because if he if he did that, he'll just
be sweeping our sin under the rug and
then he wouldn't be just. He'll be
merciful.
>> He's doing the same thing. It's just
that it's just that someone else is
dying for your punish. Like it's like
saying that I robbed somebody. But okay,
but it's like if I robbed somebody
>> and the punishment was 5 years in
prison. The person I robbed would do 5
years in prison for me to stay out of
jail.
>> What if they paid your bail amount?
>> That's the That's not You're saying
we're saying like the punishment. The
punishment. It's not a a deference to
the punishment.
>> Well, so if we're talking about the
punishment itself, if the punishment is
handled and dealt with, then justice is
served, right?
>> Not if not if the person who the
perpetrator is not punished, but
somebody else is.
>> No. If if according to the law, if
according to the law, let's say like
what what what let's say you robbed a
bank. I don't know whatever you said. I
forgot what you said, but let's say you
robbed a bank. And um let's say in
according to the law, the perpetrator
has to has to do jail time or somebody
can come in his face willfully and do
jail time for him. Yeah.
>> Right. Let's say that that's the law.
>> Yeah.
>> So let's say you rob the bank um and so
you're going to be going to jail, but I
love you. I don't want you to go to
jail. And so I do it on your behalf. I
take your time. I do your time in jail.
So according to the law, justice is
served and the crime is dealt with,
right?
>> But yeah, that's what I'm saying. But
like why does it have to like in in how
do you know that there's the ore in this
situation?
>> Uh because that's what that's if we're
talking about God's law, it's the price
of sin is death. So and the way to get
out of that is is atonement atoning
sacrifice. So it's either we face God
with our sin and therefore face eternal
death, separation from him, or someone
comes in and takes my place and dies the
death that I deserve.
>> But you believe that he is God. So you
believe God died to stop the separation
of God.
>> I believe that God came took on flesh to
represent me and you and everyone else
because we couldn't represent ourselves.
He came in the form of men and gave his
life in the flesh. Obviously in his
divinity if without flesh he he can't
die. There's nothing you know death is
separation from body and soul. He
doesn't have a body to separate from.
But if he takes on a human nature and
takes on a physical body he can
experience death in that way. And so
that's what he did to represent mankind.
>> How does he have two natures in one? How
is he and human at the same time?
because he has the properties that make
him divine and he has the properties
that make him human. We can have two
properties sometimes like don't like
>> they don't mix.
>> Yeah.
>> No, they don't mix. We could we could
talk about christologology after this.
Just right.
>> I mean I mean like you're how how are
the two natures like some some of the
things like in both natures they don't
make sense if you add them together.
It's like saying he knows everything and
he doesn't know everything at the same
time.
>> Well, no. It's it's like if um according
to his divine nature, he knows all
things, right? He has all knowledge.
According to
>> according to human nature, he grows in
wisdom and you know grows in stature. He
grows up as pertains to human nature.
It's not saying that the divine nature
knows and doesn't know type of thing.
>> He doesn't know divine nature.
>> Yeah. But in human nature, you don't
know everything.
>> Before Before this, brother, before
this, because we could talk about
Christologology. I have no problem with
that. Do we first understand how um God
coming in the flesh in the person of the
son and giving his life for us that that
is perfectly just according to God's
law? It's not logically incoherent.
>> I I still don't see why he would need
that. I understand what you were saying,
but I still don't see why. Like
>> it's not him that need it. It's us.
>> Why can't he just sweep them under the
rug? He's pretty much doing the same
thing.
>> Because then he wouldn't be just
>> adding an extra step. It's just adding
an extra step. if he swept it under the
rug, he would be a corrupt judge, not a
just judge, right?
>> He could be a forgiven judge,
>> but a a corrupt judge, though, right?
>> I mean, if a jud if someone's going to
jail, and they're going to serve some
time, and they didn't and and can they
like
>> What if What if that judge sweeps that
sin under the rug, I robbed the bank,
and the and the judge says, "Oh, no.
It's okay. I I'm I'm very forgiving, so
you're good to go." Is that just?
>> Depends. I would know how you said it.
No, but like what if what if instead of
>> stay in the scenario? It's not just if
he
>> scenario sameen how you said it. No, I'd
say no. But like what if what if the
judge lightened up the sentence? For
example,
>> how can he lighten up the sentence when
the law says this?
>> The law look robbing a bank is jail
time. That's what the law is. So if he
goes against the law, well, no, you
won't do jail time. You'll just do
community service. Is that just Is that
just Hello?
>> Hello. Can you hear me now?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, I was saying if let's say cuz
the the law is going to prison, going to
jail.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's say the judge is like, "Oh, no.
You know what? He won't go to jail. You
just do community service." Is that just
>> No.
>> Exactly. It's still corrupt. So, the
reason why God cannot sweep our sin or
crime under the rug is because he's
perfectly holy and just. So even if uh
we can understand the justice of a human
judge, God is infinitely more just than
a human judge. And there's no way that
he will let sin go, that he will just
sweep sin under the rug. There's no way.
He has to deal with sin because that's
his character. It's his nature to be
just and holy. But at the same time,
he's also loving and merciful. So there
needs to be a situation, a solution
where God is both just and merciful at
the same time without sacrificing
either. The way he does that is in the
person of the son. He comes himself,
takes on the form of man, represents
mankind, takes on the punishment that
man deserves. So the so sin is punished
and dealt with and the mercy and love of
God is bestowed on all those who freely
accept the sacrifice and gift that God
has offered us which is himself. So
God's love and his justice are satisfied
at the same time without sacrificing
either or. Make sense?
>> Okay. But how is it just then for for
Jesus to die? How is it how how you
justify his death? Jesus is God. Jesus
loved us.
>> Yeah. Jes Yeah. Jesus is literally this
is what Jesus says, bro. Jesus says in
John chapter 10. Let me show you, man.
Let me show you this. John
10 verse 17. We're going to read this
portion here. He says, "For this reason,
the Father loves me because I lay down
my life that I may take it up again. No
one takes it from me, but I lay it down
of my own accord. I have the authority
to lay it down, and I have authority to
take it up again. This charge I have
received from my father. So Jesus
willingly, one, he willingly gives his
life up for us because he loves us, and
two, he has the ability to do it and to
rise up again in power and authority.
Death can't hold him. So he's capable of
doing this and willing to do this.
>> Okay.
>> Yep. That's the gospel man. So the
gospel message is God loves mankind.
However, mankind rebelss against God. So
mankind has to face God's wrath. But God
loves mankind. So what does God do is
that he takes up his wrath himself and
represents mankind on our behalf so that
we don't have to and makes us right with
him reconciles us back to him. That's
the gospel.
>> Okay. Then why does on the cross why
does he say you have forsaken me?
>> Ah man I'm glad you asked that. Why on
the cross does Jesus say, "My God, my
God, why have you forsaken me?" He says
that, by the way, do you know who's
sitting there at his uh at his cross
mocking him and stuff?
>> Not really. I just know like about the
story of him getting stabbed by his
friend, I think.
>> No, not his friend. It's a Roman soldier
pierced him in his side to make sure he
was dead. But you have a Jew, the the
high priest, the chief priests, and the
and some rabbis and Pharisees. They were
there mocking Jesus while he's on the
cross. These are Jews.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Also some of his uh disciples like his
mother was there. Um John the apostle
was there. So Jesus cries out on the
cross. He says, "My God, my God, why
have you forsaken me?" This is why this
is I ask you this question. Because for
the Jews that are there listening to
him, who hear this? The Jews as they
grow up, they're taught the Torah and
they're taught the Psalms. They recite
it over and over. They get they memorize
it, you know, almost wholeheartedly.
Okay? It's part of their culture, their
tradition, their ritual. So Jesus, what
he does is, "My God, my God, why you
forsaken me?" He's actually reciting
Psalm 22. Psalm 22 starts off literally
like this. My God, my God, why have you
forsaken me? So for a Jew who's
listening to this, they would recognize
exactly what Jesus is reciting, what
he's quoting. And we'll see why it's
significant. Why does Jesus quote this
particularly? My God, my God, why have
you forsaken me? Why are you so far from
saving me? From the words of my
groaning. Oh my God, I cry by day, but
you do not answer and by night, but I
find no rest. Yet you are holy,
enthroned on the praises of Israel. in
your f and in and you our fathers
trusted and they trusted and you
delivered them right just to skip for
you know a little bit time he says but I
am a man verse six and not I'm a worm
and not a man scorned by mankind and
despised by the people all who see me
mock me they make mouths at me they wag
their heads he trusts in the Lord let
him deliver him let him rescue him for
he delights in him right so they're
mocking him sound familiar
>> so we drop down watch what it says here
in verse It says, "For dogs encompass
me. A company of evildoers encircles me.
They have pierced my hands and my feet.
I can count all my bones. They stare and
gloat over me. They divide my garments
among them. And for my clothing they
cast lots." So they're gambling over his
clothes. They pierced his hands and feet
and they're mocking him. This is exactly
what happened to Jesus at the cross. At
the crucifixion, the Roman soldiers
divided his garments. Matter of fact,
let me just show you this so you can see
it yourself. They uh divided his clothes
and gambled over his clothing and cast
lots over them. Here it is. Uh here it
is right here. Verse 22. When the
soldiers had crucified Jesus, they took
his garments and divided them into four
parts, one part for each soldier, also
his tunic. But the tunic was seamless,
woven in one piece from top to bottom.
So they said to another, "Let us not
tear it, but cast lots, for it to see
whose it shall be. This was to fulfill
the scripture which says, "They divided
my garments among them, and for my
clothing they cast lots." So the
soldiers did these things. So we see
Psalm 22 being fulfilled right before
our very eyes. So why does Jesus quote?
Why does he cry out, "My God, my God,
why have you forsaken me?" because he's
quoting a psalm that literally points to
him being the Messiah who suffers a
crucifixion. He's pointing to a
prophecy. So in that the Jews that are
there can probably recognize what he's
quoting and then come to repentance, but
they're hard-hearted. But this is why he
quotes this. This is why he said it. By
the way, the Psalms was written a
thousand years before Jesus came to
earth and was born. So a thousand years
before he was he came to earth before
he's born a thousand years it's
prophesied about his crucifixion bro in
detail that
>> yeah all right what about like the
heinous laws in the in the Bible
>> we could get to that man but first I
want I want to you got to say something
to this
>> I I understood why he said that he's
trying to like he's he's fulfilling the
prophecy
>> or he's like showing them
>> back to the prophecy
>> and and don't you think it has weight
that this was prophesied in the first
place.
>> Yeah.
>> Doesn't it show that God actually
revealed this? That this was his plan
all along that he actually spoke
objectively in history. Regardless if
we're a Christian, atheist, Muslim, we
we have to account for God predicting in
detail what happened to Jesus a thousand
years beforehand.
>> Uh-huh.
>> The only way is prophecy. God really
spoke. So, this has to be the word of
God. You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> that's why this matters, bro. I'm not
just showing you this just to show you.
I'm showing you this because I'm I'm we
have proof that this is the word of God.
Cuz only God prophesizes. Only God tells
the end from the beginning in detail
before it happens. That's his signature.
That's his that's his uh as some people
say, that's his um his fingerprint. His
fingerprint is prophecy. Nobody else can
copy this. Nobody can mimic this.
>> Yeah. you know. So, all right. Um, with
this being said, bro, cuz I want you to
come and I'm giving you reasons why you
should believe the Bible. Now, if you
want to, we could deal with a couple of
uh of your objections when it comes to
the laws.
>> Um, cuz I'm almost I'm almost out of
time. So, let's let's go ahead and get a
couple of your objections. And what
what's a law that you said that you have
a problem with?
>> I don't remember the verse exactly, but
it's the one about the the 50 shackles
of silver. It's like if you uh if you do
something to a certain like I'm not
going to say the word, but if you say do
something to a certain person, then you
have to pay 50 shackles of silver to her
dad and then
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
>> You know what I'm talking about.
>> No,
>> it's the uh Let me find really quick.
>> Oh, you're talking about uh
>> Deuteronomy 22. Yeah. 22 vers 28 to 29.
>> Yeah. So, okay. So, let's go ahead and
make sure we read it. So you're you're
thinking that this talks about if a
woman is graped, right?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. So it doesn't it doesn't say that.
So let's let's go ahead and put it on
the screen.
>> All right.
>> Deuteronomy
22. Let's do uh let's do 25 to 29. And
then we're going to do Exodus
22:E 16. And then over here, let's go
ahead and get uh see.
Let's do this really quick. Really
quickly, make sure you guys are hitting
the like button. I know there's a lot of
you guys that's watching. You guys
forgot to hit the like button, man. Come
on now. What y'all doing? Go on and hit
that like button. Okay. Oops. Not not
19, 29 or 28. All right. Okay. So, let's
open this up. So, the versa is over here
on the right. We're going to do 25 to
29. Okay.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So it says now by the way all
of these are hypothetical cases. If this
if this this is what you can do in this
type of situation. All right.
>> Yeah. It's a law. It's not like
>> so it says but if in the open country a
man meets a young woman who is betrothed
and the man seizes her and lies with her
then only the man who li lay with her
shall die. But you shall do nothing to
the young woman. She has committed no
offense punishable by death. For this
case is like that of a man attacking and
unaliving his neighbor because he met
her in the open country and though the
betrothed young woman cried for help
there was no one to rescue her. So this
is obviously talking about grape right?
>> Yeah.
>> So in the situation of grape the Bible
says that the man should be put to death
but the woman is nothing is supposed to
happen to her. Okay. So it dealt with
the situation of grape. Now, we're
dealing with a situation that has
nothing to do with grape. Here it is. If
a man meets a virgin who is not
betrothed and seizes her and lies with
her, they are to and and they are found.
This is important. Notice how it doesn't
say that in the in the in the grape
case, but in this case, it talks about
how they are found. So, they're found
together. Then the man who lay with her
shall give her to the father of the
young woman 50 shekels of silver and she
shall be his wife because he has
violated her. He may not divorce her all
his days. So this is talking about
consensual sexual intercourse. This is
why it says that they are found because
they're doing
>> exactly.
>> Say that again.
>> It used the exact same wording though.
>> Where what are you talking about? It's
the seizing the seizes her and leaves
with her. It's the exact same wording.
>> Yeah, but in Hold on. First of all, in
the great context, notice it says that
the woman cries for help, right?
>> Yeah. But but here it's talking about
like afterwards. Here it's talking about
if they are found during the thing.
>> No, this says this has nothing to do
with the situation above. Verse 28 is a
completely different scenario. Has
nothing to do with grape. Verses 25 to
27 has to do with grape. This is why it
says it doesn't mention about the girl
crying out for help or nothing like
that, but mentions how they are found.
They're found together.
>> It's because they're doing this in
secret.
>> Yep. Um why in other translations does
it not use that? Like it says
specifically grape in other
translations.
>> Oh, don't the one that holds that is the
the NIV, I believe.
>> Yeah. And that's wrong. It's incorrect
because the word sees here it doesn't
mean grape at all. What it mean looks
over here. Notice how the first one
comes up to manipulate. You see it on
the left here.
>> It says violate.
>> Well, that's not the word here.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, to manipulate.
>> But how do you know which one's correct,
which one's incorrect?
>> Because the word is not has nothing to
do with grape. It doesn't say that's not
a definition. So, when NIV translate the
word is grape, that's that's literally
wrong. So, you can catch your you can
you can see no just like like just pay
attention a little bit. When it says
seizes her, the word in the Hebrew is
tapas. Tafas can you be seized by
capturing um physically or mentally
manipulated. That's why one of the first
definitions here is to manipulate i.e.
seize. So it means that he manipulated
her into having sex. He seduced her. The
same scenario is here. This is the same
scenario is in another law too or not
another law. It's the same law.
Deuteronomy is just repeating the laws
that were mentioned before, the laws we
see in Exodus. And it says the same
thing in Exodus.
>> What? Sorry, guys. Asked, what's the
Greek word that it uses in the other
verse?
>> It's Hebrew. It's Hebrew.
>> Oh, sorry. Hebrew. What you said here
used to?
>> Yeah. Tapas.
>> All right. What What's the word in the
other verse?
>> Well, the word here in Exodus, I don't I
got to pull that up and see.
>> No, no. In in Deuteronomy, just the
verse where we we we said it
specifically like clearly talks about
it, but Oh. Oh, okay. Yeah. Sure. Sure.
Sure. Let's see. So, verse uh 25. Oh,
yeah. It's a different word. So, it says
um but if a if in the countryside a man
finds a young woman betrolled and forces
her, the word is right here. It's
chazak. Chazak.
>> But you seized her last time.
>> Well, that's in the English translation.
I'm going notice. No. Are you looking at
the screen?
>> Yeah.
>> I feel like I feel like you're not
looking at the screen. You looking at
the screen. Hello.
>> Hello. You looking at the screen, bro?
>> Hello,
>> bro. Are you good? Is your connection
good? What's going on? Hello. Hello,
Ryopoulos. Can you hear me?
>> Hello.
>> What's going on with your connection,
man? You can't hear me? Can you see me?
Hello. All right. Looks like we got to
cut it here. I'mma kick you. See, I'm
going to see if he comes back. See if he
comes back. But yeah guys, as I as I was
saying, the word in Deuteronomy 25 where
it actually talks about grape is a
different word than what is used in
verses 28 and 29. The word chazak which
means to seize by force to grab hold of
by force to force someone right the word
to does not mean that means to seduce.
It can mean to capture. Um, but it means
to seduce in this context. And how we
know this is because Deuteronomy is just
repeating the law that is in Exodus
22:16 where it says, "If a man seduces a
virgin who is not betrothed and lies
with her, he shall give the bride price
for her and make her his wife." This is
literally what Deuteronomy is just
repeating. has to do with seduction, not
grape. They are consensual people who
slept with each other in secret, which
is why it's saying, "And they be found."
So, the God of the Bible is actually
holy. So, I hope that uh that helps for
anyone who is uh who gets approached
with this objection. The Bible condones,
you know, forced sexual activity.